so
like i've had a smartphone since i was
in eighth grade so if i really i was a
pretty innocent kid to be honest and it
didn't like i was fine with that
but like
honestly if i wanted to google something
it's pretty easy it's right there
i was uh completely but i think it it's
social media is kind of like um a
detached way of looking at things i
think when you learn certain patterns
from your parents certain mindsets when
you learn not to talk about certain
things like i was sexual quite early on
just because of my family dynamic but i
received a lot of shame for it and i was
shamed for kind of the way i was acting
and it wasn't necessarily a healthy
thing but because it wasn't spoken about
and it was kind of shut out i didn't
really learn how to deal with it
hopefully healthily what do you mean by
shamed
um
so i found myself in a lot of kind of
quite sexual situations early on um that
was kind of the way i searched for
physical intimacy because i didn't
really know how else to do it it was
kind of the way
um and i received
a lot of backlash content from people
who found out about it like um teachers
friends and friends of parents who
didn't want the kids to be friends with
me because i was sexually active
my mom never really spoke to me about it
but i could feel kind of that
disappointment in her so it's never like
outright but it's more like a shutout
you're kind of freezed out for acting a
certain way that doesn't really
um go with those conservative values do
you do you feel like we should be
encouraging young girls to be more
sexual i think we should encourage the
conversation about it okay i think
that's the issue the issues that we
don't talk about it's not necessarily
encouraging girls to be more sexual but
knowing that if they have certain urges
they have certain feelings if we can
know about it and have that conversation
about it because you can learn all types
of stuff from the internet right it's a
great place to find information but it's
also a great place to find
misinformation and so i think it's just
important to be having that conversation
about it and who do you think the one
that should be should be initiating that
conversation
do you think it should be parents do you
think it should be schools
um i think it should be collective
society i think we should all be
encouraging that conversation i don't
think it should be a taboo topic to be
talked about i think we should be
speaking about it completely because i'm
of the opinion that i think you can
judge a society by the way
the women act in that society i think if
you go to different nations around the
world and you look at the how the women
act in that society you will generally
get to know how the society is i feel
like the in the western world
the way the women act in this western
world you can kind of tell that society
is
degenerating in my personal point of
view i really do believe that
degenerating and that's because
for me
children have to be raised and they have
to be raised by someone so
women are the first teachers of children
so are the fathers and fathers no the
first teachers of children are women
because that's where the child is at
mostly it's mostly with the woman so
it's getting most of its teaching most
of its nurturing from the woman and if
the woman is not right
then the child's not going to be right
but it depends what you define as right
like yeah yeah yeah well morally correct
right
um a morally functioning fully
functioning
uh
part of society i think if i think if
the mothers and the women of society
aren't functioning correctly then that
will be handed down quite easily to the
children but you're you're trying to
define what's morally correct for every
woman ever but even though
like it's not the same as for everyone
else you know it's it's not about what's
morally correct it's just like actions
have consequences right and men are
biologically like they're repulsed by
girls that have slept around and that
they can't help it because historically
they had to ensure paternity so you can
you can't make that go away in them
so you say like the same way the same
way sorry the same way like we want a
tall guy because we wanted a guy that
could protect us you can't get rid of
our biology it's just there and like no
matter how much society tries it's it's
still there no guy wants to date a girl
that's slept with like 100 dudes i feel
like there are some guys 100 there are
people who don't have an issue like guys
but if you if you okay there are
exceptions but it's not the rules yeah
right okay okay
let me just let me just go around do you
want to date a girl that's slept with
100 dudes no thank you do you want to
date a girl that slept with 100 dudes no
do you want to date a girl that slept
with 100 dudes no and i've asked this
i've asked similar questions on the show
like i've used different numbers 50 70
whatever it is you can't
shame men into wanting what they want
it's it shouldn't be about what the men
want in that sense we shouldn't define a
woman's sexuality by what the men want
yeah we shouldn't define a woman's like
freedom to explore her sexuality about
what men want
right so you can you can do like i don't
care what other people do i don't think
it makes you a bad person just because
someone sleeps around like that's that's
what they want to do but
the point is there's consequences and so
if you sleep with a lot of people less
less guys want to date you but it's the
judgment and the taboo of sexuality that
that comes from kind of thinking that a
woman is dirty because she slept around
so much when that shouldn't be the
mindset but that's the mindset that's
been taught because of sexuality but
woman has been so controlled and
restricted and defined like marilyn
monroe who was a sex icon but it was in
so many different relationships where
the men were awful to her because they
took advantage of advantage of her
sexuality wanted her to be the sexual
icon but she also profited she also
profited off of it yeah so so you can't
say like she also committed suicide
because of her relationship with the
kennedy brothers the bedrock of society
our family
if anything that that's showing that
like being promiscuous doesn't lead to
good things right but it wasn't it
wasn't so promiscuity that led to it it
was the men that she was involved with
that she chose to be involved with so
it's like you if you make choices there
are consequences
and actually molested as the kids and
that's why she was like that
she was she was sexually molested as a
child i'm not i'm not if someone's if
that happens to someone that's terrible
i'm not blaming that on her but i'm
saying as an adult she made choices and
there were consequences and i have a lot
of empathy i think that's very sad she
made so for example she had a
relationship with tennessee williams who
she made the choice to be in a
relationship who she wanted to be in a
relationship with he saw her as this
ideal woman that he wanted because of
her sexuality but when he was with her
he wanted her to be like the madonna
horror complex he wanted her to be the
monado but she didn't fit that and so he
was horrible to her as a result and then
and left her and she made a choice to
love but because of her sexuality she
wasn't
okay i i don't know what you're talking
about the madonna works oh sorry i don't
know i don't know we divide the feminine
into like the virgin and the [ __ ] like
mary magdalene and mother mary that sort
of thing it's how we separate the
feminine in order we separate things we
don't understand it's weird to think
that women can both be that purity and
that's sexual well i mean like my point
is you pick who you date so like
if you keep finding yourself in toxic
relationship after toxic relationship
you have to look at yourself i don't i
don't know anything about marilyn monroe
i'm not going to pretend to be like the
expert on i don't i don't know what she
did in her life but my only point is
like actions have consequences and i
don't care what people do but just don't
complain about the consequences the
consequences of
a
let's say more sexually liberated
society is that
all societies most societies and most
nations are built off a core
family nuclear family structure okay the
west seems to be straying more away from
a nuclear family structure and so
if the men are building their society
right generally men build societies
women nurture what's in the society
so if the men are building the site and
women are nurturing what's in society
and like i said the women aren't right
and we need a nuclear family structure
yet and still this
this um society teaches women to be
independent you don't need a man you can
do it all by yourself okay that is going
to affect the moral fabric of the
society in which we live in but if you
make the point about women making bad
choices about partners if they stop
making those choices then they're wrong
for making the choices not to be with
partners who are going to be horrible to
them wait because it's a way to say that
so so because of feminine sexual
liberation
they don't need a man they become
independent that's the thing yes but
it's come from a space where women make
choices to be with the wrong men so they
decide to make different choices to be
independent to not pursue those options
so then what's what's the right choice
so you're saying that they made that
choice because of
so so in in this situation where monroe
made the decision to be with those
toxic just as an example not her
specifically but made that choice to be
in those toxic relationships and and now
we're on the other side where women are
choosing to be independent choosing not
to be in those toxic relationships